[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview notre invité
aujourd'hui mathieu langlois bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur ancien médecin
chef du raid hauteur de médecins du raid
aux éditions albin michel bienvenu sur
ce plateau et merci à d'être parmi nous
mercier ou alors mathieu avant de
revenir sur votre parcours au sein du
raid et sur ce que vous avez vécu vous
avez grandi en région parisienne vous
avez fait des études de médecine et il
me semble qu'à vos 25 ans vous êtes de
garde et vous vivez en événement un peu
particulier
alors c'est là je qui j'étais en train
de réfléchir enfin qu'un voilà donc en
fait la gt j'étais encore étudiant enfin
j'étais jeune
j'étais externe encore donc jeune
étudiant en médecine et je quittais la
montagne pour venir prendre garde au
samu de 92
et je crois une demi-heure après avoir
récupéré même pas mon mot bip j'ai été
avec un médecin et un ambulancier on
était sur les attentats
au rer b à saint michel est-ce que cet
événement vous avez vécu à confirmer
quelque part votre vocation
il fait partie évidemment des événements
importants qui m'ont
rassuré on va dire dans le sens où je
j'avais confiance en moi par rapport à
mon à ce que je devais faire dans des
situations particulièrement difficiles
après j'étais jeune donc
j'avais là aussi la naïveté de la de la
jeunesse
j'étais j'ai heureusement progressé et
est confronté à beaucoup de situations
difficiles qui m'ont permis ensuite
d'avoir une vraie expérience vous
rentrez au raid en 2007 comment est-ce
que cela s'est fait alors en fait j'ai
été recruté par un ami via le sport
ou qui connaissait mon parcours médical
mais nos relations étaient plus amicale
et sportive et donc c'est lui qui m'a
proposé de rejoindre
leurs aides et c'était une évidence pour
vous
ce sera compliqué alors ça a été
c'était une évidence ni compliqué c'est
à dire que j'ai pris le temps par contre
de mûrir entre 2007 et 2008 j'ai pris le
temps de mûrir cette décision est pas
seul parce que c'est pas un choix facile
est donc faux c'est ce que je disais
ensuite aux jeunes médecins que j'ai
essayé de recruter c'est que c'est un
choix qui doit être partagé avec votre
environnement personnel et familial en
particulier en 2012 vous est ensuite
nommé médecin médecin chef qu'est ce que
ça impliquait pour vous ce poste
j'imagine qu'il ya tout temps il ya le
côté décisionnaire qui entrent en jeu
dans ce poste alors des décisions tous
les médecins et tous les opérateurs tout
le monde comprend après
c'est un rôle de responsabilité où vous
êtes vous fait le lien entre la
hiérarchie qui n'est pas médical et les
différents médecins aussi bien au niveau
2 de l'échelon central donc pour l'état
major et des antennes qui était à
l'époque c'était encore des antennes
raid c'est est ce qu'on appelait des
groupes d'intervention de la police
nationale noc et gipn
mais déjà l'idée était de d'uniformiser
la médicalisation et de l'accord donnait
donc ça c'était mon rôle vous dites que
c'est un choix qui doit être partagée
par votre entourage comment est ce qu a
réagi justement votre entourage l'idée
c'est pour ça que ça prend du temps
parce que c'est
c'est pas forcément une décision facile
il faut qu'elle soit parfaitement
comprise et admise par par vos proches
et à l'époque mais mes enfants étaient
petits donc il je l'aurais pas vraiment
demander leur avis mais par contre ma
famille c'était vraiment important
qu'elles qu'elles adhèrent
à ce projet parce que qu'est ce que ça
implique pour votre camp vous dit qu'il
fallait qu'elle adhère à ce projet
qu'est ce que ça implique concrètement
pour votre entourage alors après en 2000
2007 2008 on n'avait pas encore vécu
toute la période de kiva 2012 a
maintenant malheureusement la période
des attentats ou le haut le niveau de
menace et d'intensité quand même
montez au moins d'un cran et à titre
d'anecdote j'avais j'avais
repéré un jeune médecin qui me
paraissait être le parfait profil pour
intégrer leur aide et je lui ai dit dès
le début je suis dit voilà il faut j'ai
compris tu étais intéressé mais il faut
que ce projet tu le partage aussi avec
tes proches et il venait d'avoir un
petit bébé et
je ça a été on est resté en contact mais
je sais que ça a été pour lui un
déchirement parce que sa femme
ne voulait pas qu'ils s'engagent mais
lui c'était après les attentats donc
je vois là on a le monde a changé oui
alors 2012 donc vous êtes nommé médecin
chef du raid et c'est aussi l'année où
vous allez être confronté un événement
tragique la tuerie perpétrée par par
mohamed merah le 21 mars donc une équipe
du raid est envoyé chez lui pour
l'appréhender vous faites partie de
cette équipe là qu'est ce que vous
retenez à l'époque de cette première
grosse intervention alors moi je suis
arrivée avec l'équipe de renforts donc
dans un deuxième temps il y avait un
médecin prend un médecin qui étaient
déjà sur place avec la première équipe
ce que j'ai retenu c'est surtout ce
qu'on en a à tirer comme enseignement
sur l'organisation et en particulier sur
la coordination avec les services de
secours c'est à dire c'est à dire que
après 2000 donc après le
la ferme ra on s'est dit avec donc le
patron de l'époque amaury de
hauteclocque on s'est dit qu'il fallait
il fallait qu'on travaille sur ce qu'on
a appelé ensuite le thème des des
tueries de masse et être capable
d'organiser des secours quel que soit le
nombre de victimes dans une zone qu'on
appelle la zone rouge mais killzone 2
dangers extrêmes dans lesquelles les
secours ne peuvent pas s'engager et donc
qu'il fallait et pour ça depuis ce temps
là on a donc développé une doctrine
opérationnel pour pouvoir répondre à ce
type de situation on a eu de la chance
c'est de cette préparé pendant trois ans
avant le bataclan mais l'idée on l'a eu
en tout cas elle a vraiment mûri après
cette la ferme la ferme ra justement
quelques mois plus tard le 13 novembre
2015 comment est ce que vous êtes alerté
de ce qui se passe
peut-être vous êtes à ce moment là mais
en fait c'est assez c'est quelque chose
ça peut paraître fou mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on connaît par coeur parce qu
on est en permanence d' alerte et donc
on est
on est appelés régulièrement sur nos
téléphones mobiles peur
pour retourner au service pour
différents types de missions et ça c'est
pas quotidien
beaucoup beaucoup c'est du travail et
c'est de l'entraînement mais des
missions en fait très régulièrement donc
le le téléphone qui sonne ou le bipper
qui sonne c'est c'est quelque chose pour
nous d'assez familier vous vous êtes
envoyé au bataclan donc nous en fait on
est on retourne tous ça c'est la
procédure normale on retourne tous au
service pour s'équiper pour partir en
goût constitué et
le patron jean michel fauvergue décide
d'envoyer des équipes sur le bataclan et
des équipes sur les terrasses et donc on
divise en deux le la réponse mais enfin
le des médecins et donc il ya deux
médecins qui partent sur les terrasses
et de médecins qui partent au bataclan
vous arrivez au bataclan oui qu'est ce
qui se passe à ce moment là alors c'est
passé c'est d'abord c'est évidemment un
choc même si on est ultra entraînés et
préparés et comme je voulais dit on
avait ça faisait trois ans qu'on était
en train de travailler vraiment sur la
réponse à apporter pour nous les
médecins et pour les opérateurs de aussi
mais leur côté
la réponse à apporter à des scénarios
type tueries de masse ou prise d'otages
massives donc à la fois on est sur un
scénario qu'on envisageait écart doute
aimé qu'on envisageait et
et après quand on arrive il ya quand
même un effet bien un effet de choc
malgré tout
on accepte entre guillemets
quelques émotions qu'on va maîtriser
alors c'est quand je dis ça c'est poste
c'est plutôt à posteriori que j'ai
analysé ça comme ça mais parce que ça va
tellement vite mais néanmoins c'est là
c'est à dire que quand on arrive moi je
me souviens où je couche je crois me
souvenir de m'être dit dans ma tête mais
qu'est ce qu'on fout là parce que vous
voyez déjà des corps partout vous voyez
des policiers qui vous disent
planquez-vous satire voyez que vous
n'êtes plus sûr du tout sur un exercice
que vous êtes vraiment dans le dur quand
vous rentrez dans la salle l'attaqué
toujours en cours alors quand on rentre
dans la salle ils ont rentré un peu
avant autour de 23 heures donc la lata
qu'elle a dû elle a débuté il ya déjà
très longtemps et il ya le policier de
la bac déjà intervenu et qui a fait en
fait c'est lui qui quand ils rentrent
avec l' usage de son arme contre le
terrorisme qui est sur la scène fait
cesser la tuerie je crois qu'il ya
encore des tirs après par le par les
balcons mais dans la salle il ya plus de
tirs à partir de ce moment là c'est lui
qui a fait cesser la tuerie et après
juste avant que nous rentre il ya déjà
une colonne de la berri et
l'équipe de l'équipe rapide du raid qui
est arrivé et quelle est la première
chose que vous faites lorsque vous
rentrez dans cette salle est bien là
c'est c'est là où en quelques secondes
quelques minutes on passe de l'analyse
de la situation qui demande aussi de
l'expérience essayer de comprendre
rapidement ce qui se passe et moi mon
objectif c'était évidemment surtout pas
de me préoccuper delà de l'aspect menace
de tra lisation de la menace c'est pas
mon job moi mon job c'est voilà qu'est
ce qui se passe sur le plan des des
victimes et comment ensuite on va
pouvoir apporter des solutions et des
solutions rapides malgré une menace
toujours présente et justement comment
est ce que vous allez organiser
l'évacuation des victimes alors on
l'avait là encore une fois s'il faut
bien comprendre que c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait largement travaillé en
exercice néanmoins quand on est plongé
dans la dent dans la réalité on est dans
il faut être agile il faut s'adapter ce
qu'on a prévu ce qu'on avait fait même
deux jours avant la veille j'avais fait
un exercice bon ben c'est pas la vraie
vie mais les outils sont là donc j'avais
et j'avais vraiment confiance à la fois
dans notre capacité à organiser notre
capacité technique et notre capacité
humaine j'avais confiance en nous les
médecins mais évidemment aussi dans tous
les opérateurs et tous les policiers qui
étaient là et donc je savais que on
allait vite mettre en place dès
ce qu'on avait des circuits d'évacuation
et vous d'extraction qu'on allait faire
ce qu'on savait faire néanmoins en
s'adaptant
énormément parce que la situation et
puis on est sur le nez vraiment face à à
la détresse humaine on ait pu face à
juste
des plastrons en plastique comme dans
les exercices par exemple vous dis juste
que vous êtes vous êtes adapté à la
situation est ce qu'il ya des choses que
votre instant vous a vu faire qui n'est
pas dans le protocole que vous n'auriez
pas fait par exemple j'aime pas le mot
instant ce que c'est c'est animal
j'aime le mot intuition
donc oui on a oui il mais là aussi c'est
a posteriori qu'on dit bien pourquoi on
a pris cette décision ou pas celle là
encore une fois c'est une rencontre
entre des intuitions mais qui sont
qu'on n'a même pas le temps
d'exprimer et puis tout votre bagage
technique
bagages humains pour faire face à ces à
ce type de situation merci monsieur on
va marquer une courte pause on vient
dans un instant
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview si
vous nous rejoignez notre invité
aujourd'hui et mathieu langlois ans
ancien médecin chef du raid mathieu on
parlait donc delà de ce que vous avez
vécu au bataclan juste avant la pub il
me semble que dans votre livre vous
racontez qu'il ya un petit problème
technique qui vous avait fait enlever
votre votre cagoule votre casque est ce
que finalement c'est quelque chose qui
vous a aidé alors c'est une faute parce
que j'aurais pas dû le retirer parce
qu'encore une fois quand on est
intervenue la menace était réelle
néanmoins j'ai j'avais ce problème
technique qui faisait qui fait que
j'avais un casque lourd sur la tête qui
qui bouge et c'est impossible c'est
absolument impossible de travailler donc
j'ai décidé de l'enlever comme j'ai
enlevé le casque me suis dit je vais
enlever aussi la cagoule et c'est là où
je me suis aperçu mais là encore une
fois a posteriori que ça avait été un
avantage dans le dans lol dont le lien
humain que j'ai pu avoir aussi bien avec
les policiers que je parle pas des
policiers du raid que je connais qu'on
se connaît par coeur je parle des
policiers
de d'autres services de la bague de dvd
de la sécurité publique et puis
évidemment surtout des victimes le fait
d'être probablement à visage découvert
dans la relation de confiance qu'on
avait besoin d'eux de créer de créer de
façon ultra rapide où on est à la fois
entre fermeté et bienveillance et
empathie mais il faut être faut être
ferme vous êtes là pour agir si elle
vous écoute il faut qu'elle vous fasse
confiance et qu'elle accepte la décision
que vous allez que vous avez prises et
que vous avez avec l'objectif qui est de
les faire sortir le plus vite possible
fou qu'ils l'acceptent et il y avait
évidemment des victimes qui était dans
un tel état psychologique il était haut
ce qu'on appelle en état de sidération
et on m'envoie là on a on n'avait pas le
choix il veut les faire sortir la menace
était toujours là donc il fallait dans
ce rôle c'était de les faire de les
faire sortir mais
l'idée c'était de créer ce petit lien de
confiance est probablement que le fait
d'avoir
tomber la cagoule m'a peut-être aidé
j'imagine que si pendant le cette
évacuation vous avez dû être confrontés
à des choix parfois difficiles
sur le traitement des victimes par
exemple oui mais c'est alors c'est une
question qu'on me pose souvent
évidemment mais faut bien comprendre ses
notes c'est notre métier c'est notre
rôle et les médecins du raid sont pas
des des bébés comme j'étais par exemple
quand je suis rentré dans le rer b
c des médecins justement concours
d'expérience de la détresse de l'urgence
et
finalement cette partie assez
assez technique à ces professionnels de
notre métier
est presque plus facile que le lien
humain par exemple dont j'ai parlé juste
à juste avant
kima il ya une telle intensité
que c'était c'était presque plus
difficile de est plus important à mes
yeux que uniquement la partie technique
on appelle ça du triage je déteste le
terme mais plus de la de faire des choix
et des priorités des évacuations faire
des gestes techniques médicaux c'est ça
c'est quelque chose pour lequel on est
on a l'expérience on est fort mais on
s'entraîne il était l'heure quand vous
terminez l'évacuation des victimes alors
fait elle se fait en deux temps il ya la
première partie la plus importante qui
est là tout ce qu'on appelle le niveau
zéro de vaud rez-de-chaussée là et
principalement la fosse ça s'est réalisé
avant l'assaut c'est quelque chose qui
n'a à mon avis jamais été fait dans le
dans le monde ça s'est réalisé avant
l'assaut qui était qui et l'assaut il
était vers 00h20 à peu près
donc plus d'une demi-heure avant
l'assaut on avait le rez-de-chaussée est
évacuée ce qui a été plus long beaucoup
plus long c'est tout ce qui toutes les
victimes qui étaient qu ont été
regroupés dans l'est dans les étages ou
même sur le toit du bataclan et là c'est
pas moi qui ai c'est pas de mon ressort
mais
ils ont être tous on a le choix a été
fait de les évacuer par les fenêtres du
premier étage par la façade est donc là
il a fallu réfléchir et coordonnée avec
les pompiers les sept cette extraction
parce que les pompiers ne rentrait pas
dans le bataclan c'était uniquement des
policiers donc nous le médecin on était
en charge aussi d'organiser cette
évacuation par les étages et là il y
avait plus de plus 80 qu'une centaine de
victimes heureusement il y avait très
peu de blessés ce corps est complexifiée
beaucoup cette cette évacuation qu'est
ce que vous faites une fois l'opération
terminée est-ce que vous rentrez chez
vous comment comment ça se passe ces
jours d'après alors droit à commencer
par le début quand quand on rentre
d'abord on rentre tous ensemble
sur la base pour se changer et là moi le
nom mama seul mon seul souhait c'est de
prendre une douche et de et de jeter
toutes mes affaires
donc ça c'est la première chose
évidemment que je fais quand j'arrive
dans le livre ce que je dis c'est que
c'était la douche la plus longue de ma
vie je suis pas sûr mais en tout cas
elle était très longue et et elle elle
m'a probablement débarrasser d'autre
chose que de uniquement
il ya les autres enfin je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails
et puis après là j'ai eu une mauvaise
idée c'est que je me suis dit avec un
des autres médecins des jeunes médecins
que j'avais recruté bon on avait on
n'avait pas vraiment envie de rentrer
chez nous et je me suis dit on va passer
à la pitié salpêtrière où je travaillais
et donc nous v'la parti je paye doit
être 4 heures du matin
à la pitié et ça c'était une mauvaise
idée parce que d'abord
il commençait à travailler il était en
décalage par rapport à nous et donc ils
ont reçu
un nombre incalculable de blessés deux
victimes et donc il était il travaillait
eux de façon très dure donc on n'avait
absolument pas notre place et puis on
avait déjà fait notre boulot donc ce
n'était pas une bonne idée et les jours
d'après comment ça se passe comment on
reprend son quotidien
et ben on reprend en fait ces paris fous
mais on leur prend assez facilement en
le lendemain moi j'ai passé jusqu'au
soir où on a retravaillé on est on est
partis avec leur aide le soir on a été
engagée pour aller procéder à des
arrestations mais la journée était une
journée tout à fait normal chez moi en
famille où on en a on n'a absolument pas
parler de ce qui s'était passé pendant
la nuit
parce que c'était pas c'était quelque
chose d'assez habituel et voilà donc
c'était une journée normale il ya donc
le procès qui se déroule en ce moment
vous y avaient participé c'est important
pour vous c'était important
c'était important oui oui je sais comme
je sais pas
je sais pas ce que les familles de
victimes
ont retenu de ce que j'ai pu dire aux
témoignages lors de mon témoignage met
donc je oui je pense que en tout cas je
les
jeux les faits avec avec sérieux parce
que pour moi c'était important de
raconter
de raconter devant la cour ce qui
s'était passé et puis les enseignements
qu'on avait et on en avait tiré sans
sans me cacher ce moment sont en jeu
quels enseignements justement tiré
aujourd'hui
alors sur un plan professionnel
sur le plan professionnel on en a attiré
énormément d'enseignements moi j'ai
comme je vous ai dit j'ai quitté il ya
quelques mois mais on n'a pas attendu le
procès pour en tirer des enseignements
depuis 2000 15 depuis alors lendemain
non mais je me souviens je crois que le
dimanche soir on a fait une réunion déjà
entre nous médecin pour déjà
fixer les idées fortes et puis après ça
a pris beaucoup de temps mais
d'essayer de voir
d'abord d'analyser les faits et c'est
pas si simple
vu la dimension exceptionnelle de 2,7 de
cette opération donc prendre le temps de
vraiment analyser
avec un oeil critique c'est à dire que
il le but c'est surtout d'essayer de
voir ce qu'on va essayer d'améliorer et
il ya forcément c'est comme judy c'est
un tel drame même si on était préparé il
ya 130 morts c'est il faudra en tout cas
mon objectif à partir du du lendemain de
l'attentât ça a été de voir qu'il
fallait qu'on améliore encore même si je
suis persuadé on a fait quelque chose
comme jeudi qui n'a à ma connaissance
jamais été fait dans le monde et en plus
après j'ai beaucoup partagé un
international donc ça m'a confirmé ça
mais il faut surtout pas penser qu' il
n'y a pas des enseignements à tirer
voilà et c'est ça c'est ce qu'on doit
aux victimes est ce que justement les
enseignants vous allez tirer sur le plan
professionnel ont aidé par exemple les
polices européennes
oui et là il ya quinze jours j'étais
entendu par exemple sur le procès de
manchester de l'aréna où il ya eu 22
morts
alors si c'était pas du tout pour
critiquer ou pour analyser ce qui
s'était fait c'était pour montrer ce que
nous on avait mis en place comment on
avait agi par rapport
au drame du 13 novembre et les
enseignements qu'on en avait qu'on en
avait tiré et que comme je vous ai dit
on le partage mais
tous les médecins où toutes les forces
spéciales européennes
ont pas attendu le des procès pour pour
évoluer pour tirer des enseignements
comme j'avais fait mois avant il y avait
eu le j'avais rencontré évidemment les
équipes qui étaient intervenus par
exemple en norvège sur sur l'île d'utoya
on s'inspire évidemment de ce qui existe
qui s'est fait et heureusement c'est des
drames qui sont tellement rares à
l'échelle mondiale que on a l'obligation
de partager on a parlé des enseignements
vous avez serré sur le plan
professionnel sur le plan personnel
c'est un sujet compliqué beaucoup plus
compliqué sur le plan aux personnels sur
le sur ce qui s'est passé ce soir là je
encore une fois je
alors j'aime pas parler de fierté ou de
choses comme ça parce que c'est
impossible
vu
le drame humain que ça représente mais
je sais que j'ai donné mon maximum et
que les gens qui étaient avec moi ont
donné leur maximum ce soir là
et donc ça c'est pour moi c'est c'est
avec eux entre guillemets l'obligation
aussi de se dire qu'on a on a fait notre
maximum on avait quand même prévu ce
type de scénario et on a fait quelque
chose qui va entre guillemets était
une première et c'était ce qu'il fallait
faire c'est-à-dire d'extraire très
rapidement les victimes du doute de la
zone de danger sans attendre que la que
la fin de faire la neutralisation
complète de la menace
après sur le plan sur le plan humain
seul après la pré bataclan et est pour
moi très compliqué pour plein de raisons
donc je vois la g j'ai plusieurs
sentiments mathieu langlois vous avez
écrit un livre dont le titre est je le
rappelle médecins auraient deux éditions
qu'albin michel en collaboration avec
frédéric ploquin pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez choisi d'écrire sur cette
expérience c'est important alors là
aussi c'est très naturel en fait ça
faisait quelques temps que je voulais
écrire un livre sur la vision du médecin
sur les opérations du raid et sion
particulier en insistant sur l'humain ça
c'était quelque chose qui me qui me
trottait dans la tête depuis depuis un
certain temps et est en voie il faut un
trail avec un copain qui m'avait dit
mais mais il faut absolument que tu
écrives bon à l'époque je me sentais pas
encore la capacité d'écrire un bouquin
et puis est arrivé le le le le 13
novembre
après le 13 novembre j'ai entendu et lu
un peu tout et n'importe quoi et je me
suis dit mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut
c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère
humainement ce type de la praye
l'après drame faut faut dire la vérité
même si elle fait voilà sans chercher à
faire plaisir à flêtre faut dire la
vérité mais il faut les dire ce qu'on
fait en amont on apprend un métier
n'attire le médecin son rôle c'est
d'arriver à aborder des sujets
difficiles grave la mort
est d'arriver à accompagner des familles
accompagnées des patients mais il sans
cacher la vérité après voilà faut pas
être bête soit au faux pas être
technique trop technique faut pas être
brutal il faut c'est ce qu'on apprend
dans l'est pas pour moi l'expérience
médical c'est ça
et j'ai eu cette analyse par rapport à
ce qui s'était passé
exactement la même en dix ans mais n'en
faut raconter ce que la vérité
en l'expliquant voilà ce que l'on
pouvait lire et tout et n'importe quoi
sauf que malheureusement quand il ya
trois terroristes qui rentrent avec des
armes lourdes avec des gelées
explosif dans un théâtre
malheureusement c'est dramatique mais il
ya des mots
merci beaucoup mathieu langlois d'être
revenu sur le plateau de la grande
interview je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin anesthésiste réanimateur et
hantz un meilleur médecin chef du raid
hauteur donc de médecins du raid aux
éditions albin michel merci encore
berciaud c'est à la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi sachez
que vous pouvez retrouver cette
interview sur notre site internet à
l'adresse arte france point tv
[Musique]